[Music]
what's up everybody we are doing a
end-of-year wrap up video 2018 so we're
going to recap our year cuz be kind of
pretty productive and like big year for
us yeah yeah I didn't think it was gonna
be bigger than last year's last year was
our wedding you know that was such a
special year it's kind of cool because
then every year it's like we have like
our year that is special to us and
differently Louis this year this year
was like what's the theme at this
I think this year's theme was travel
hard like traveling crazy travel through
the tribal blowing out yeah getting the
travel bug out that was definitely 20 18
years ago know for sure like I'm kinda
tired of traveling and it's funny
because when we're uploading this video
we will be in Hong Kong as ironic it's
very ironic
so we're filling this the day before we
leave still have impact we need a pack
after we film this video you ever get
heard this video up I know are you live
I know but yeah we decided consumer last
year we kind of did a year recap as well
so we're like oh you know we should just
do this every year and then especially
since this year was really exciting for
us we got to travel a lot we got a new
car the family we've got new family
members I changed my look again that's
true chopped off all your hair here of
this
you know it's funny I really miss Meilin
I'm here now and I was just rewashing
so before filming we were looking at her
channel looking back in all the videos
that we uploaded this year and I came
across that video when I chopped off all
my hair and I was so excited
and I was so like yes getting rid of
this dead weight because hair is just it
wastes so much it was just I'm tired of
it I'm sick and tired of this long hair
and then now I'm like you're telling
your something no TV no no checked out
it was just it wasn't like a regret
thing
no I wasn't telling myself no because I
definitely was happy and I definitely
have loved it this whole year but now
I'm over it now I'm just like cool I'm
ready to get my long hair back this time
of the year next year you're gonna have
long hair net I hope because I'm
actually getting worried it's been a
long time since my last haircut and it
hasn't grown so I'm like oh no it can't
grow up my hair so that's kind of
getting a little worried I'm thinking
well with my age
trip hold I mean I'm 29 30
I know 30 is like ancient no authority
is so all its do that you're doing
anyways yeah oh yeah people hit their
prime minute when they're 30 I feel like
that's why we're getting our stride
right now that's a lot of people I don't
know I don't really feel like I'm having
my prime I feel like a lot like my
primer has been reached and now I'm on
the D company biologically
intellectually and systemically
the system of society but yeah
biologically for sure I feel my huge
caption note to me catching up to me too
like oh my god my mind is just it I feel
fried now like I feel like every time
I'm trying to speak the words don't come
out the way they want to come out and
then I've been watching these most
recent videos and like as time is going
on I look like sleepier and sleepier and
sleepier and I'm like today what is
going on with me that's why my new
year's resolution for sure is to like
try to get healthier hopefully I can
like get out of this biological funk
that I'm feeling quickly I get like that
too sometimes where you just kind of hit
this point where your brain doesn't you
feel like there's a block on it or
something like that
your laude yeah especially with what we
do like with the logging and stuff it's
like like some days my mouth is like
wire invisible with when there's new
wires me I've been to my tongue-tied
feel like my tongue is like flat ironed
so it's like flat and I can't articulate
like I can't enunciate well so you can
flat iron tongue and get wired lips so
anyway back to recapping the year where
do we travel to this year oh my gosh I
actually have this app it's just perfect
does it really smell ah let me guess
yeah Peruvian food today other dinner
you're so funny
anyway so I have this app that I've been
trekking on my trip so it's really
convenient not sponsored but another
brand oh yeah don't even say it
why because it's convenient I want to
share something with you guys I'll trip
it and so like that's where you can plug
in all of your your flight itineraries
your Airbnb or like your hotel or your
car rental stuff or even the few book
like excursions and the places you go
all that's up all your confirmation
numbers you can import it into this app
here and it has this feature where it's
called travel stats and so for example I
will show you my travel stats so this is
for you showing off the twin well you're
talking about our year this one for 2018
let's impress this Travel stats right
there it's very impressive well I mean
they know they've seen all of our
travels this year so that those are our
trouble stats for this year so those are
the child stats it says here that I
because I did including your travels cuz
you went to New York and punch rings on
your own so that is not in here and then
I went to Cancun and New York without
you so these are for the trips that I've
been on so it says I told sixty four
thousand nine hundred and twenty-one
miles there were 42 total days I was
vacationing or gone or somewhere there
were
13 total trips 8 countries visited and
20 cities visited that's pretty cool
and actually that's not you man I don't
even know if that's including I don't
think that this is including Hong Kong
yet cuz I haven't gone yet so that's
pretty cool so we have been to many
places where have we been
it's the list so we went to San
Francisco twice this year the first time
was with my brother the brother cuz I
didn't wear clean underwear brother now
cuz he was like my brother too so now
he's like brother-in-law
brother you don't want a brother-in-law
it's peaceful like you're studying yeah
brother sir oh there sister
anyways go with them so that you're like
came over to the west coast cuz they
live in Texas and it was really cool we
got to spend some time with them it's
like our parent my parents cuz usually
when we see them we always without the
entire time it was just the young adults
yeah you got to go a couple of the two
bars how did you like that trip I really
liked that trip I think me and my
brother we haven't had a whole lot of
chance to a thing bond with each other
on a like like strictly brotherly level
like it's always were you know there's
either Isaac in tow or my parents and
like I don't know it's just not that
that's a bad thing or anything but it
creates a different atmosphere you know
and like growing up for my brother we
spent a lot of time just with the two of
us and you know we were able to relate
on that brother level you know I think
with us going out to San Francisco by
ourselves and bringing our significant
others I think we were it was really
cool they kind of I even told them I'm
like this is so cool because like when I
was a kid I used to imagine like what it
would be like I'm like how far like 10
you is fine you know
I'm looking at my five-year-old brother
I'm like wonder what it's gonna be like
30 years from now and breathe it both
have wives and like we're gonna have
like our own lives or we're gonna be
hanging out in the future so cool still
be brothers and we're not gonna be ever
like brothers apart you know in San
Francisco whoo damn boat I'm
experiencing that you know it's so cool
oh yeah that was another one I want to
do more of those for sure yeah that was
like that was so much fun and then yeah
like you said it does totally create a
different atmosphere when it's the
entire family together but it was really
cool to just have the four of us like
bond on like just where it's just the
four of us and then also you get to
really bond with people where you travel
that's why I like the ho jayegi family
we all love traveling because that's
when we really get closer to each other
it's like you're getting a glimpse into
living with that person and then
experiencing a whole nother place
together it just it gives you like a
whole nother outlook on the relationship
that you have with that person so yeah
traveling with them it was really cool
so we went back to San Francisco a
second time yeah like months apart like
she's like - I think it was really short
guys do not have been two months later
DejaVu it was so cool because we got
invited to go see pics I like to go
visit the Pixar studios and that for me
was like a little I would always see
like little documentaries or like little
snippets of people talking about how
amazing working at the Pixar studios is
and like I had that had always been a
dream of mine I'm like oh my god I wish
I couldn't go there and then when I
found out that it's not open to the
public
I was like dang I don't think I'm ever
gonna get the chance to go there so
being able to go there this year like
being invited there and I'm like with my
family like I was just like over the
moon like I could not I mean you guys
could see from that video I was like 10
times way more excited than Isaac was
cuz I'm like he doesn't understand like
he doesn't
yeah yeah we got like honestly it's like
all these opportunities that we've had
this year with working with brands and
working with Disney and everything like
it is all thanks to you guys because if
it wasn't for you guys supporting us we
would have never even had the
opportunity to work with these brands so
I want to tell you guys thank you so
much so so much for all the support that
you guys have given us and I just truly
appreciate all the love that you guys
cuz every time we have like a
sponsorship like a video that's
sponsored you guys like you get that
money I'm like oh I love you guys so
much thank you guys so much for being so
supportive because in the beginning was
really hard when people would be like
wow how sell out it's like oh my god
like that I'm just like no it's not like
that
and then like people will be like can't
they just take anything that they throw
at them and I'm like no that's not the
case like we really do like these were
actually actually really enjoy working
with the brand you'll stuff - I like
working Brando's just because time
before I got the whole YouTube thing I
wanted to be a like a music video
director and commercial director yeah
you would do these what were they called
expect commercial spec commercial yeah
so basically it's like auditioning your
talents as a film director to do
commercials and stuff and like they had
these contests back like tonight I did a
butterfingers little speck of honey
buddy buddy buddy actually won some
money a couple thousand bucks so I was
like oh this is so fun and like
vitaminwater I've ever seen that
vitaminwater e of Doritos and it's crazy
to think that ten years after that I'm
doing YouTube blogs and then I get the
opportunity to work with brands and
basically do commercials again so you
guys just see the surface of it but it
just goes where you deeper into that
like I can honestly 100% tell you that
we would not promote something that we
didn't genuinely love 100% like we would
not be promoting thing or it's a brand
that we had always been curious about
we were interested in or it aligns with
our views another big thing that
happened this year was oi6 started
playing piano
yeah and he's excelling like crazy so he
so in movies old now a lot of land like
the main reason why he wanted to play
piano was sea-washed lalala I didn't
even expect him to like the movie we
thought using before and you love the
character that Ryan Gosling played and
you loved and you loved the suits yeah
the piano we loved dressing in suits
I mean you dress her up in a Santa suit
I'm sure he's pretty spiffy yeah so ya
said you fell in love with the piano as
in the movie and I don't have to play
piano a little bit here and there so I
would you know teach him like a few
things here and there yeah but I mean
who would go to your parents house who
always got right on the piano like he
loved it so much in your dad showed him
how to play a couple songs and Isaac was
just like he just did it yeah we were so
impressed too I'm like how he could
remember everything that was being
played on like everything that his dad
was teaching him and so we're like
alright we're gonna go home order a
piano we got the smart piano which we
actually never use it for that purpose
which is where you plug in an iPad and
then the keyboard lights up and it could
teach you how to play certain things
Isaac doesn't use that because we
actually take him to a music teacher so
he learns from a actual teacher it's
better that way yeah an ability humans
from you because every night when he
gets home from school were like alright
20 minutes three minutes of piano and
then kissing they're helping guide him
through his piano homework and stuff so
he's been excelling in the piano I'm so
proud of him and I keep telling him
because sometimes he'll have those days
where he's like call it honor practice I
don't want to deal with this that's good
though cuz I feel like that's that was
one of the best learning tools I had
growing up too as I did piano and
there's more days that I didn't want to
play again within the days I did want to
play piano and but my parents more or
less forced me to do it but I feel like
that's a great learning tool because
when you get older like there's a lot of
things on my
you're just kind of you're gonna have to
suck it up and just do it I hope he
sticks with it and we're gonna try our
best to you know positively motivate him
to keep going with piano yeah so back to
the whole traveling think we went to
Vegas a couple times
JK fan yeah we had a company trip yeah a
company trip and we went back for the
McGregor fight oh that was cool that was
so fun and so like exhilarating
trance-like just actually experiencing
an MMA fight in person that was really
our it was outside of our wheelhouse to
of things that we normally do we never
like but like II make sense for you oh
it's just like he works in a USC whiskey
and boxing I'm like you're so into it
right now yeah like for me as an
outsider like I don't know anything like
I never like just nothing right so being
in there and seeing everything go down
and then like Kobe jumping over the cage
and like just going crazy I'm like what
is happening right now what is happening
this is so cool by witnessing it
straight now like this is awesome so
cool like Oh huge McGregor's personality
is and like seeing him in person it was
just a whole another level I'm like that
it was really cool I can't even speak it
was so cool
you know me I'm all about experiences
and Brian sure is and like so for me
experiencing that was really cool like
that just goes into lately another
challenge I have a check off the list
yeah that was cool so we did that and
then we also owe it went to our very
first like traveling YouTube event we
might play with Lumiere playlist yeah we
never go to these YouTube events ever we
never get invited and then we only went
to that because those three take K so JK
got invited
it's true it was really interesting
speaking of being old and feeling old
playlist makes you feel like you're
ancient yeah - or there were like
nothing but little teenage social media
stars everywhere and I'm like oh my god
I guess so I don't think you would have
been under dance I wasn't like I wasn't
like a super nerd or anything but you're
like I'm a definitely was like in on
Carter's classes and stuff well I had
friends over in honors class that
weren't complete nerds but you know that
would be me like I was an honors kids
but you know to take that role we anyway
I felt like I shouldn't be here like
Isaac should be here because there was a
little kid like his age kids and then
yeah so that was really weird
anyway so but you know the same trip we
yeah we visited your cousin I was about
to mention that yeah we cousin Jenny she
was pregnant with baby Axl so I got to
see her when she was pregnant and then
when we were on our trip to Puerto Rico
on the way back we got to stop by and
see baby Axl and just born so my new
family member it was really awesome to
see him sometimes will FaceTime and I
see him growing up oh my god Mike oh
sure so fear we gotta make a trip up
there soon and I gotta go see him again
and then eat into my baby ate and he's
so big I see him growing oh my god yeah
that's it Isaac he's at the age where
human I when I met eyes again yeah I
cannot put that Center together okay
what happens it's okay I'm here I'm done
thank you mr. Beck so we did that and
then speaking of Puerto Rico we got to
check out Berto Rico and then this year
was so cool too because we got the
chance to work with three
tourism boards that's just like that's
incredible it's so amazing we got to
work with the Tourism Board of Houston
the Tourism Board of Puerto Rico the
Tourism Board of istria
which is a region in Croatia that was
hands-down my most favorite trip of this
year like Morocco was amazing
Morocco we booked a group tour together
so it was like through a different
company like we you know we did that on
our own
but having Istria host us was like a
once-in-a-lifetime experience I think it
was amazing I don't think history is one
of those things where I don't think I
would have it would ever cross my radar
ever in my lifetime had they not reached
out to us yeah that Croatia would have
never crossed my radar and then much
less the actual little region of mystery
I know but it's so beautiful it is in
Jim and I would recommend anyone to go
there yeah it's like uh uh it's it's die
for me if I saw the vlog but like just
the vlogs it doesn't even compare to
what it's like and I would just like to
take the time to just just say the word
truffles truffles we were drowning in
truffle it was spectacular and then
truffle hunting with dogs that was so
cool
I didn't eat first of all and even know
you had to go hunt him I did not know
that that was the thing or even tasting
olive oil like what we did a lot of like
pinky out kind of stuff from mystery ax
and man there's really no words for it
no memory now that I'm telling you this
I can already picture the funeral that
Casey's gonna put over as we're talking
about Istria and I just wish I could be
teleported back to those moments again
so Istria was great Morocco was amazing
on down play Morocco Dokdo was Hamels in
the Sahara Desert that was definitely
the highlight camels and the Sahara
Desert I never and thought I would
that in my life that was one of for sure
a bucket list thing there's like you
know all the traveling we did this year
it didn't necessarily hit my bucket list
of places that I wanted to go to there
must go to places yeah we didn't check
any of those up actually well Baraka
husband one hooker yeah Marvel was one
so that definitely for sure I did check
off a few things but overall though it
wasn't like the pregnancy bucket list
that we have mentioned before yeah so
like about a year ago yeah a year ago
maybe a little bit more now we mentioned
a pregnancy bucket list that we had to
do this a matter traveling at these
specific places and yeah we're gonna
mention to you as much places because
it's just a really long list but yeah
like we didn't really had any of those
places but honestly like the experiences
I've had this year because it was mainly
me that was putting that pregnancy
bucket list thing over our heads
I am completely like satisfied I'm like
this is amazing this is perfect this is
great let's bring on the baby but we're
just waiting that's on record now okay
I've told you that every time he's like
so are you done with the traveling I'm
like yes I'm done I'm tired and the next
thing I know I booked a trip to Cancun
like or no actually right when I said I
was tired of traveling was right when I
booked a trip to go visit my family well
that I for a quick weekend I'm like oh
my god I'm tired of traveling but I
thought it goes through my ground
something yeah so honestly like unless
other things come up or other really
amazing opportunities come up then it's
gonna be really hard for me to like turn
it down I'm still like I still have that
adventure or in me like the wanderlust
girl than me well enjoy Hong Kong is
rare in Hong Kong right now and as
in this video no I love home check out
our Instagram by the way over there
posting some really amazing stuff you
know right but yeah I love Lancome I've
been there once before in 20 year what
14 2014 we went it was during the summer
it was really cool so it's gonna be
really interesting to see Hong Kong now
during Christmas time a whole different
season so every time I've gone I like to
please no it wasn't that's why you guys
went to Hong Kong that's why you guys
went to New York yeah to show Isaac what
New York is all about yeah that's
exactly why I took Isaac to New York
because I was like dude we're gonna see
Hong Kong you don't even know what Hong
Kong is like but first you had to see
New York because New York is gonna look
like a tiny little nothing compared to
Hong Kong yeah he loved it it was so
cute to a heavy heart just like our time
together like just me and Isaac I think
the last time we had travelled just me
and him alone was when he was about 4
years old we went to go visit family in
Mexico and that's not even fully
traveling alone because we met up with
family in Mexico so I think this is the
very first time that we were completely
just the two of us in a different place
and that was really special for me
because I really hope that Isaac was
able to create some like long lasting
memories just the two of us cuz I feel
like you guys spent a lot of time
together and because I'm he's always
gravitated to like you know you like the
male figure in his life
yeah and like for me I'm just like you
know that's not you know and I'm always
I've always worried that my thing I hope
he doesn't forget the experiences we've
had together cuz anytime he mentions
anything about us together it's always
like oh yeah mom I remember you got
angry at that thing or like I remember
um I had to be at that place but then
you got upset or something like he
somehow just remembers the negative
things which is understandable because I
think as humans were wired to have the
negativity of Pop
the trauma yeah and so and like I think
it's actually like psychologically it's
been like scientifically you figured out
that you remember things more when
you're like angry or scared or like you
know like no we're just moving into
negative stuff like yes
exactly look at the news that's so hard
to find fun things I know that's so true
so yeah like that's why I like I
understand the way his psychology works
but I'm just trying to like pump in more
positive things in there so it could
override the negative stuff cuz I mean
obviously you know I'm his mom I'm gonna
like discipline him here and there and
I'm just worried that that is magnified
more in his mind and a good stuff so the
New York trip was really important to me
for that reason so I really hope that he
enjoyed it just so much cuz I was just
like are you having fun are you having
fun are you having fight like the whole
time I'm like trying to make sure to do
this I just really want you to be happy
and have fun and like remember me in a
good light thank you well it's just the
stage he's that it's his expression of
appreciations than at 100 yeah yeah in
fact I feel like it's never there until
you're older like way older I mean do
you think you matter now that you're 30
I think I'm the closest never been to
like fully appreciating my parents for
sure now cuz I have Isaac now you know
it's it's like nine so he's a parent is
he and appreciating most likely yeah
like that about my parents it goes full
circle yeah until you you get to that I
read this one comment one time someone
wrote that a case he likes to say the
word full circle a lot and he says it
almost nursing with a reason
[Music]
Canada my skin if you two I'm sure
everyone yeah what was I saying
something about full circle Isaac yeah
yeah yeah I think you'll appreciate you
in Estonia see I'm pretty sure we're
about to enter the yet the roughest
patch it's okay I can't wait hopefully
not hopefully not like the way until
he's a parent because I don't want him
to be a parent that young don't repeat
the cycle because mom does I review the
cycle is my mom she had me when she was
18 man Isaac when I was 18 so unlike no
Isaac don't do it anyway moving on to
the rest of the year another place that
I went to this year that you didn't
accompany me was a little how to do them
yeah it was a girls trip and it was so
much fun and I was recent so you got to
see that video don't thank you that's
crazy - lemon so you came back and I was
like labeling our project file for the
vlog that was it but the label of Cancun
and then you're like no it's Tulum it's
like a couple hours away from Cancun so
in my mind if I was anything I was like
well if anything happened like an
emergency happened I've gotta Cancun for
you well I mean there were four other
guys I think five other great four five
I can't met five five million guys you
could have asked true and I hope one of
them could have figured it out I don't
know but yeah it's two hours away from
Cancun so that's why I was like it's not
Cancun is Tulum okay can we we did fly
into Cancun - weird - till them together
that's where the Mayan ruins are we saw
that together because we did a trip to
Cancun like the earth all right vlog was
not a vlog I just had a GoPro at that
time and I record a lot of footage you
should find that footage one these days
do you like the throwback vlog what you
guys want to see that because I know I
see that because we have a lot of
footage like we went to Italy together
we never really set foot in random
footage of like stuff we that's exactly
with that New York New Year's trip was
we released that that's true there's
only one actually it didn't ever involve
the throw like we have calling soon we
have Hong Kong we have Italy yeah if you
guys want to see that let us know in the
comments cuz I vote for yes I want to
see those videos okay because those are
like in the early years of our
relationship it's true and every time I
look back to photos from that time and
like transports me back to that where I
feel like those like early stages of the
relationship we're like oh my gosh I
like this guy I don't really know him
that well how did your accent come out
oh yeah you're right I think part of
2019 agenda well what happened yeah I'm
gonna try and get those GoPro vlogs done
this year and then people a mission
statement of mine yeah there'd be
awesome uh what else happened this year
Isaac had his first big project this
year
mm-hmm I was fun too he had two projects
I'm like stop growing up Isaac if you're
not with the start doing stuff with you
did the school work I'm like I know like
I don't want to do school I know they
honestly don't like these tortured
parents maybe partnership is homework
there's a lot for the parents to take on
but I think we did pretty good just fun
though I mean
it's fun at the end of the day you have
got fun for yourself because you did a
good chunk of it and I kept having to
stop him oh my car like arts and friends
I know but like I had to be the party
pooper a lot I'd be like Casey you need
a like Isaac do his advanced project
that's how I realize a lot of parents
end up being like going like the lazy
parenting route because it's just easier
for you to do it and like the kids never
learn that's your lazy parenting is out
there not helping or your kid out at all
or doing everything for your kid because
you just don't want to deal with
teaching them yeah I think he's letting
your kids suffer but then pushing them
just a little bit guiding them yeah a
little bit several more nutty Floyd that
suffering I think you put it this way
once where you're like parenting it's
like driving a car with bad alignment as
soon as you let go of the wheel it
starts going out of like it's so crazy
you kind of have to like hold on to it
you know guide it a little bit more
another big thing bringing it back to my
brother buy a house good I know congrats
to Carrie and Diana can you guys have a
beautiful home and I'm so jealous I want
that one and I think I think seeing him
get that house really motivated us to
wanna try and attempted buy a house in
LA see the thing is we're saving yeah
yeah I like honestly deep deep down
inside I'm like yeah right we can never
get a house it's just so ridiculously
expensive here in LA and every year just
gets keeps getting worse and worse and
worse for those of you that don't know
what buying a house means or entails in
LA for a three hundred thousand dollar
home in Texas that would be the
equivalent of a 1 million dollar home
yeah we did start saving and we're
really hoping that somehow in the future
the cards are dealt in our favor and
we're able what if I
well we haven't bought a house yet this
year but no we didn't buy it I'm so
happy because now by the time you guys
see this video you're gonna know already
because the video is Lana and I'm so
happy dragon
I work Tesla I gotta stop saying like I
know it's your Tesla no you claimed
ownership by driving you weigh more than
I do well because I turn it in my car
for it there's a little bit more my car
than okay so we actually got the Tesla
like like a couple weeks ago and then
we've been trying to open him and not
share it well I've been wanting to say
it ever since we ordered it and we
ordered it a month ago I think it was a
week after no week before my birthday or
something like that it was like near my
birthday yeah just ever since we ordered
it I've just been wanting to scream it
from the rooftops and want to come up to
Civic to Tesla's I know it's so cool I
love it and Isaac seeing him so happy
it's just been like the best part of it
all because every morning he likes
getting chopped off in the test line you
just saw it like cute no but definitely
once we get back from Hong Kong I first
sure I wanted to make a video of like
all the cool things that the Tesla can
do because there's so many little Easter
eggs that that they've incorporated into
the car and it's really cool and I never
knew how much a car could really affect
you it's pretty crazy but I think of him
like when we moved into this house we're
drove like you just feel a little when
you're at rest nicer you know and I
totally feel better just driving in this
card this year is the really cool tip is
I'm learning Mandarin now I've been
taking Mandarin class
which I've mentioned in another vlog
like I said I just picked the best
student so I did miss quite a few
classes or I would get there late I
haven't been studying on my own time
which is obviously what's gonna help me
learn the language right now that I'm in
Hong Kong as you guys are watching this
I hope I can be practicing with Mama
Baba because they do know Mandarin and
so I'm gonna I'm gonna bug them would be
like hey what is this Chinese character
mean you could probably end up speaking
Mandarin to most of the Hong Kong enough
to speak it like I really say like learn
how to say ice water or whatever no I
just no water so a choice
no that soy is in Cantonese very
delicate situation of tones right now
between Cantonese and Mandarin I know
good then I'll tell him something
in Mandarin needs to use it up to
Cantonese I'm like no you're screaming
is how I know is but that's what it was
with Italians like I understood it when
I heard it because it's so similar to
Spanish but I couldn't say it because I
would want to say that Spanish part but
yeah so it's confusing but yeah it's a
Mandarin is been pretty cool I'm really
looking forward to learning that like
conquering that language or just being a
pro at it
I'm never for me what can you not know
that's like to tell you you would know
of the top 3 power languages of the
world Spanish English and China Mandarin
Chinese and I barely know English you
should learn Spanish montano I should
leave town - to learn Spanish please oh
my gosh this women there are no that is
a mess anyway you just good but you
don't know more cause you look so like
insecure you like what do you how do you
say I don't know it's very no sit no see
and yeah I was trying to think of that
like I can respond to this it's just
that I remember how to save the things
would say when you don't know anything
you know say no say no say yeah when in
doubt in Spanish just say I'll say
nothing it's like a sieve but CEO thanks
no sick yeah no simple anyway so the
last thing of this year it's been very
exciting and very important to us our
course launched it has been so amazing
to see all your hands as messages and
how how well you guys have received this
so I just wanted to clear up a little
bit though because there are some people
thinking that like they've kind of got
confused with this course was really
four so we're not trying to market this
to people that are trying to be
youtubers and trying to make a living
off of this because we in no way was
were a terrible YouTube we was never
claimed that we're professional
youtubers to point where we can teach
you it know do daily vlogs and we don't
like the whole thing and you guys know
this have you've been following this for
a while the whole purpose of this
channel is to capture our memories and
just have like a video diary where we
just so happen to share with you guys
and like you know we bring you guys into
our world aren't lives and do things we
like on the show yeah and it started off
at like for me to capture memories for
him to have a creative outlet so he can
edit the way he wants and like just
express himself through his art form
craft yeah you know he's cracked me in
my creating videos so the whole course
isn't geared to like sell you on like
you guys are gonna make some money with
it no it was just me it's meant for you
guys to know hey this is the way we
create our videos that's it we're not
telling you this is how you log this is
how you should go about creating a
business of logging no none of that
it's just hey your
curious how we create our videos you
seem to really love the way we create
our videos this is how we do it and
that's it so we're just really thankful
and really happy that a lot of you guys
have been so happy about this course -
you guys have been so happy for us and
so supportive and like we just love you
guys so much for that because like I
said like who we invite you into our
lives and by tuned to our hearts and
just based on the fact that you guys are
so supportive every time there's
something good going for us like I just
I love you guys
even more for that so thank you so much
we really hope you're enjoying the
course and if you have no idea what
we're talking about you could check out
life with the camera comm we're like I
said we show you guys how we create
videos like Casey's editing techniques
just tips on how we do our videos and if
you want to capture your own memories
and you want to have like your site
Hoggy for 2019 - really vlog your own
life and not you don't have to show
anyone this could just be for you and
create your own videos and your own
memories and a nice edited wave yeah
just totally check out life with Cameron
comm and if you guys want to get a taste
test of our life with the camera vlog
course check it out we have the
three-part mini course that you can sign
up for in our Mellon list and for those
of you guys that are interested in how I
do my edits I'm offering you guys their
little glimpse into my workflow in this
blog course you guys can see one of my
project files and see how I actually
pieced together my edits and we also
have an aesthetics package that I've
curated with music from close friends of
mine that are royalty free for you to
use for your own minutes so check it out
like for the camera calm and it's kind
of cool too because right now we have a
special promo going on where up until
the stroke of midnight January 5th
turning into January 6th that's when the
promo will no longer be available so you
can check that out at life with the
camera calm and we really hope you enjoy
it thank you so much for joining us this
entire year if you're new welcome
check out the previous video so you can
know exactly what the heck we were
talking about this is your first video
and you muses point oh my god good for
you man I'm so glad that we're able to
entertain you in a flicker around this
whole video and not even know who we are
and just hear about our past year but
yeah anyway thank you guys we love you
so much we hope you have an amazing 2019
we're so excited for what is in store
for us this next year and we just want
to wish you guys a very merry Happy New
Year
[Music]